alors j'ai eu sincèrement envie de me
frapper pour pas avoir utilisé sa plus
tôt mais vraiment et salue les vidéastes
et plus particulièrement ceux d'entre
vous qui sont youtube heures parce que
cette vidéo s'adresse particulièrement à
vous aujourd'hui
alors je sais ce titre put la vidéo
sponsors limite racolage et banon 11,0
en contact avec la marque produit payé
avec mes sous mais un lien affilié en
descriptions parce que là c'est la vie
par ce fameux accessoire dont on va
parler
il me permet de faire mes vidéos youtube
en deux fois moins de temps genre
vraiment j'ai divisé par deux le temps
qu'il me faut pour faire une vidéo comme
ici en face caméra est d'ailleurs à la
fin de la vidéo je vous dirais la
longueur du plan face caméra avant
montage et après et vous allez être
surpris en franchement ce fameux
accessoire c'est donc roulement de
tambour
c'est un prompteur ouais je sais dit
comme ça ça fait pas rêver et c'est la
monumentale erreur que j'ai faite aussi
de penser que c'était pas fou
pour ceux qui connaissent pas un
prompteur c'est un écran qui permet de
faire défiler un texte de dix courses
est beaucoup utilisé en journal télé et
sur des discours important et ça permet
de patienter dans son texte et de pas
avoir à regarder de fiches donc au début
j'étais pas vraiment convaincu et après
avoir essayé ben je me suis dit que
c'était juste la vie et qu'il fallait
absolument que je vous entend d'ailleurs
si vous aimez quand on parle vidéo
astuces tournage montage tout ça pas le
bouton s'abonner la cloche y sont alors
comment ça marche
et pourquoi c'est tellement cool déjà ça
se présente sous la forme d'un socle en
métal sur lequel on va venir poser sa
caméra juste là et en transcendant
ensuite il ya une vitre il faudra
surtout veiller à l'aller c'est hyper
propre vous allez comprendre pourquoi
après on a donc notre caméra posée sur
un socle qui nous filme comme d'hab
la seule différence c'est qu'elle le
fait à travers une vitre est infernal un
genre de couches en tissu pour englober
le tout et ne pas laisser passer de
lumière et voilà et là vous vous dites
mais comment tu affiches le texte
maintenant un bas tout simplement avec
une tablette ou un smartphone qu'on va
venir poser en dessous de moi j'utilise
l'ipod et la voice téléprompteur un jour
un lien quand description et c'est là
que la magie va opérer
l'appli permet de mettre le texte en
mode miroir à l'envers pour que quand on
le pose sur le socle le reflet dans la
vie tu reçois à l'endroit est magique
quand je suis en face je vois le texte
directement
l'objectif mais la caméra elle elle ne
le voit pas en plus cela que j'utilise
elle se déclenche quand je parle et elle
s'arrête quand je dis plus rien donc
c'est hyper pratique pas besoin de
télécommande par contre faut bidouiller
un peu avec la vitesse de défilement
sinon ça va être un peu désagréable du
coup c'est génial mais déjà un
pourquoi c'est génial et 2 il y aurait
quand même pas quelques petits mauvais
côtés d'un stack c'est soir alors on va
commencer par ce qu'il va bien
déjà le regard il est forcément tourner
directement vers l'objectif
on peut pas lâcher et ça pour un face
caméra c'est hyper important
avant je faisais surtout des boulettes
poynt de mes idées et après
j'improvisais la façon dont j'allais les
expliquer du coup mon regard et partait
un peu parfois sur les côtés mais ça
c'est fini et c'est clairement très cool
on s'adresse directement à l'audience
droit dans les yeux
l'autre gros plus c'est que avec saab à
impossible d'oublier une réplique le
nombre de fois où j'ai relancé la caméra
après avoir décroché parce que je me
rendais compte que j'avais oublié un
truc je suis sûr que toutes mes idées
seront là au moins avec cet accessoire
ville mais tel que je les ai pensé parce
que oui des fois il ya des
approximations mais bon hein je suis pas
parfait on aura aussi une meilleure
fluidité fini les que tu as tout bout de
champ on peut dérouler une des 100 coupé
et ça c'est pareil pour le viewer c'est
du confort d'écouté enfin il ya le gain
de temps dans mon cas c'est le plus
dingue
il n'y a pas de déchets il n'y a pas de
perte de temps ça déroule pour peu qu'on
soit à l'aise pour lire et interpréter
un texte surtout après avoir passé du
temps à écrire ce texte pour vous donner
une idée généralement pour avoir dix
minutes de face caméra généralement je
tournais à peu près 25 minutes
d'ailleurs je vous affiche ici le temps
du plan face comme d'origine et l'âge le
temps de la vidéo finale oui parce que
là je sais pas encore combien de temps
ça va donner pour cette vidéo mais dites
moi dans les commentaires si vous
trouvez que c'est un bon ratio mais ça
ça nous amène au point négatif le plus
précédent peut aussi se révéler être un
moins si vous êtes à l'aise dans l'impro
et que vous ne vais pas écrire un texte
au mot près pas ça sera d'aucune utilité
ça peut même être contre-productive
aussi être à l'aise pour lire un texte
qui défile et ça c'est autre chose pour
moi je me dis que ça va parce que j'ai
dis à personne que j'utilise un
prompteur dans les précédents jeux vidéo
justement pour voir si les gens santé
une différence et personne n'a grille
donc c'est bon signe c'est que ça mais
le texte faut savoir l'interpréter aussi
et enfin il ya le prix 200 balles pour
quelques bouts de métal et une vitre
plus la tablette
j'avais déjà j'aurais pu faire avec mon
smartphone et 20 balles pour l'apli ça
commence à faire un budget est là où
pour moi c'est rentable c'est que le
temps que je ne passe pas sur une vidéo
youtube je le passe à travailler sur
autre chose et ça c'est très cool et
surtout je gagne du temps sans rogner
sur la qualité sans bâcler la vidéo au
contraire vu que le texte est respectée
c'est encore mieux pour moi et rien que
pour ça je regrette monumentalement ne
pas avoir fait cet investissement avant
gens pour la formation de mariage que
est sorti ya pas longtemps mais il
faudra bien posé le pour et le contre
si vous envisagez vous équiper et bien
garder en tête que le prompteur ça va
driver de manière impeccable à condition
que vous soyez à l'aise avec au passage
j'en profite pour dire un grand merci à
david de la chaîne monsieur caméra qui
m'a convaincu d'essayer ce petit joujou
et c'est juste formidable et ce qui est
formidable aussi c'est de mettre le
fameux coup de blaster sur le pouce en
l'air qui se situe en dessous de cette
vidéo de vous abonner si c'est pas déjà
fait mais aussi d'aller voir cette vidéo
qui s'affiche ici dans laquelle je vous
présente mon set complet youtube avec
les caméras aller l'a été tout un tas de
trucs cool mais sans prompteur parce
qu'à l'époque je l'avais pas et je
regrette un petit peu quand même